[Music]
International chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017
spring chess classics
welcome to the 2017 spring chess classic
the weekend edition today we're going to
look at what happened on days five and
six here in st. Louis at least one
really big key matchup happen in each of
the groups this weekend and it really
shaped up the landscape of the standings
the 2017 spring chess classic features a
combined prize fund of more than 50
grand win the top prize in group a that
will get you $6,000 $4,000 is the prize
for group V and the top prize for Group
C is $5,000 that's because Group C is
actually stronger than Group B in Group
Aid Daria spirits from Poland
he won his game today with the white
pieces against Grandmaster Andre bearish
polish so thank you for joining me and
congratulations on your games thank you
very much take us through some of the
critical moments on this one and now I
just don't try the the light light light
pieces and he's bent on his night and
queen are pinned so and this I think is
very dangerous and tricky for for black
I thought at first the Ruby wanted the
best move and I wanted to play Bishop d2
and play this position and here I was
worried what to do because I couldn't I
can't stay because of 25 but then I
realized we were after again bishops
appraised pretty unpleasant for black
still because I'm Boka ample none but
the pawn on e5 is basically lost and at
some point I just need one move eight
free just to make sure that I'm not
getting made on the first rank and it
should be a huge advantage for wide
action
so there for which it was problem
exactly correct
Queen a3 a4 adhere I can move this idea
we should be to Bishop c3 which is very
strong I guess because I need to improve
this Bishop and I take this phone on f6
he takes takes root DC's bishops III I
think black has a bug is in trouble here
rook 888 and now my first intention was
to play g3 and this could have been very
bad move because light XD frequent x7 94
if I'm not mistaken for example after
King edge one night of tonight
immediately oops
and if King gave one then I take C 3 and
I'm queen up but root G 1 is made within
maybe one fret trying to play a 4 and 2
here I don't think and I put most likely
some some draw like this but I was
already ambitious myself here and I
didn't want to go for tougher like this
and I do before this my idea was that if
he takes here this position should be
better forward because my mobile devices
is better than comb ability of his
pieces here and I think it should be
better for but as with another third
game is not that simple
maybe I think it was the best chance for
for black here also there is move like
King which one it's very interesting but
some crazy stuff is going on going on
here like he can play Nigeria trying to
take my queen because I take Queen h3
Bishop f6 which is o and now I make him
on the 8th ranked on so some fine lines
but he can play for example h6 here we
should f6 King gauge 7 and no I just
have no idea what's going on there like
will be 7 for example 28 I mean some
nice net Nigeria the thread now and if
you guessed and then just king g6 I have
no idea what that maybe sounds somewhere
it's a kind of equal whatever what good
thing that I can still play here for
example Quinta Agito but I mean anyway I
wanted to promise like it take this and
play this position so I thought this
would be slightly better for it too but
he played rogue age 6 which is actually
bad movement was in this critical
position he made the wrong choice
because after after Queen at three it
appears that he's in huge trouble
because just rising cool gap for and he
doesn't have very good defined he played
religiously because if we root g5 and I
can just label Bishop veto and just
bringing his works and just winning so
Rho G cigs will get 497 if 94 I mean if
now rotated through T 5 there is nobody
to but I have 84 and it looks just lost
and if 90 by 97 the nine said just to
take I was thinking for him for a moment
about raga one but the night after Queen
yet like it doesn't bring me anything
real so I decided just take it upon and
play the same position on eco material
which was actually having good so it's a
pink Egyptian b2f I'd have just into
general including Kai's Quincy free idea
to and create some kind of battery here
he played this I'm just in case I might
let paid for my king yeah some before
for removed some regular improvement h4
I think was good because now h5 is a
huge spread I mean this should be pretty
bad this must be lost for black because
Keith King it's very very weak if I 5 I
can all those of the camera just a
consistent keep late 90s 96 I play
before the five Queen as I was canonized
and now 15 the gas service it basically
just lost or a little d8h 555 which for
remove what he resigned basically almost
in Italy after I said that bore because
utter Queen Estes here it just making
next move alright so just take material
so it's follows so it was very
interesting going but the non without
mistakes for from both types so last
time in the winter classic you tied for
second in Group A now you just played
the group B champion from the Winter
Classic give you a good run there but do
you think maybe you can go a little bit
better than second this go-around
I will try all over my butt
- still for game to be played after five
o'clock five rounds so I have three
points which is plus one it's normal to
be doubt I mean - lot of slaves before
me and I mean I would just play octopus
as I can and just see how things are
going
I'm a little bit I mean and I was quite
sad because of the loss to bar but he
played a good game I didn't and he I
lost I love the game
because I was there basically today but
I hope that this loss will not affect
the whole reason the whole picture of my
play and result here so I want to keep
playing good tears like maybe not today
but like for example yesterday was very
good game against Alex but also very
good game so kill today was also decent
but I mean I would just try to play
other than they can see what is what
will happen
well there are congratulations to be a
very much on your point let's take a
look at the standings after the entire
weekend of play in Group A
in Group B I'm here with Grandmaster
Akshat Chandra well a relatively new
grandmaster gets two months in right
something like that yeah
today he had the white pieces against
Najib Ikeda he was not having a very
good tournament over five at this point
here on Saturday so take us a through
this game and show us why you thought it
was remarkable sure yeah I mean the game
was very complicated I got a really good
position out of the opening and here I
used to have tonight takes a four I
thought I didn't have anything and I I
just like stopped calculating it but I
just missed Bishop 66 f66 Queen 66 is
decisive I think pretty sure it's
decisis but hey the reason I rejected it
was eight takes to be five but I just
didn't occur to me that even though her
King kind of runs to safety on the Queen
side I mean if she had chance of
blocking her own pieces and whatever
after like something like this
it's just winning I mean absolute need
to just liquidate into an endgame yeah I
mean it's completely winning it so I
seem that I would have gone to the
audience and I played Bishop f1 which
wasn't wasn't the best and she took on
e4 which is correct if you played a six
then I get to play Bishop before now and
this would be for while I wasn't working
on the previous move because she just
takes on b5 and yeah my bishops painting
so yeah Bishop 194 Bishop sorry King c1
first like Eastern Bishop before I was
still pretty optimistic here but I was
in severe time trouble here I was down
to like one or two minutes and she still
had like 15 or 20 so anything could
happen she played a really strong with
not rigid which I didn't see she has
other options to charge calculate a me I
did systems here acuity I was thinking
like if she goes nine to five I'm not
trying to hint at 93 at some moment
I think we should be - it's quite strong
just attacking the knight and the
tactics are not working for her because
also a king's exposed like she plays
something like this then we should see
six when she comes in here and I take on
the four most attacking the rook so she
has to trade and this is like one line
now scalp game takes b5 and route gauge
to route 52 and think the night's
dressed but okay I don't know how I
curse dishes because I was pretty much
playing on the increments the
calculation wasn't that great obviously
yeah she goes Knight d5 okay I can just
just take the pawn in the center so
that's nothing it rootkit is really
strong because now if I take she takes
and she plays Knight g3 and the point is
that the route g1 she was 90 to check
and she wins in exchange
so I played Bishop e2 preparing Queen 64
again she found the best webknight of
two because otherwise if she allows me
to consolidate you're just going to be
completely lost because we're King so
she has to go for it play Bishop c5
queen bee Stein I was interesting
actually I thought you'd play queen
season and still very messy I don't
really know what the evaluation is but
yeah Queen d7 I would guess one thing
that's pretty much forced see I hear I
lost in exchange but her Kingston with
centers are still optimistic but then
she found a way strong move rook c8
pinning my bishop and suddenly it's very
hard for me to meet this threat of just
Queen c7 I mean I took in the game she
played Queen c7 and I can't move my
bishop anywhere because she's got made
on c2 so I played this you have three
which is the only move setting little
trap obviously if she takes on c5 Bishop
c6 check interfering with protection she
takes it a night I just swing the
Queen and she takes a look I just give
me so she came to that but she she made
the decisive mistake and she could have
Phi which I think just losses on the
spot
I think not if I was just fine for her
actually I think we both just
miscalculated something here because I
only have many options for my queen like
okay if I play Bishop c6 check obviously
she takes on the same games obviously
winning for black but maybe there's some
mutual blindness or something like kind
of I guess I'd actually queen before
obviously I can't go like Queen f6 or
something because just take center now
our King runs to faith and completely
safe there so I have to try something
like Queen before but okay she can just
take now and Bishop d6 route 66 beat 66
okay I mean I guess the only black can
write here this dish you put f5 and that
weaken the H 5 e8 dyno and so that's why
I play Queen f6 now threatening Bishop
h5 I mean I could play Bishop hy
immediately but I liked Queen a
six-letter because it also keeps this
option open in some line and she took an
F for a holy move like what's to take
here to prolong the game but after
Bishop H 546 I was just calculating a
simple line just to crease just to
liquidate to a easily one roof gang game
and the Queen's come off I just push my
C pawn all right so she took on f4 but
it's already lost now King b1 now also
threatening right here so she has to do
something about the bishop and I played
Bishop h5 check and my attack just
crashes through and I finish the main oh
yeah very nice mate on the board is that
different I mean at the high level and
by high level I just mean anybody who
has a title basically you don't see too
many checkmates does it feel any
different to you personally whenever you
find one on the board yeah it's rare to
give me but whenever like I think I have
like I made in one I'm like extra
cautious like am I missing something
like why pony's just letting me I made
in one and like
I crazy or something so I usually take
like a little bit of time I just don't
bang it out and take like least half a
minute to make sure that it is really
machine one right it would be pretty
embarrassing otherwise oh so I want to
thank you first of all for coming for
this interview I missed you and I
basically came in a little bit late
today there's a little bit of a mix-up
and you said oh it's great I live down
the street because you live in st. Louis
now originally from Jersey what st.
Louis like so far for you you enjoyed it
yeah I definitely am enjoying st. Louis
because of amazing chess culture here
that's been created by the Cinco family
and yeah I'm just enjoying the
experience and it helps to be here for a
while yeah it's really amazing what's
been cultivated here
Marco beans in the next room like that's
crazy that's awesome okay well akshat
congratulations
and hopefully hope for the best in the
upcoming rounds all right let's take a
look at the standings after this weekend
going into Monday Group B
Group C is all about Sam seve on after
he defeated ilium is Nick this weekend
take a look at the standings in Group C
stay with us through Wednesday May 24th
as every round begins at 1:00 p.m. with
the exception of the final day see the
move by move live as it happens at just
24 calm and us chess champ calm